for a lot of guys they think that when
they're going out on a date suddenly
they've got to look sexy
so they end up mistaking the idea of
sexy with something that's too tight too
tight means you're going to be kind of
pulling at yourself all night so
remember if you are wearing a great
lightweight knit or you're wearing even
you know a jersey shirt it's great
because it shows off your physique but
you don't want to see buttons pulling
think about a color that always gets you
a compliment if you have blue eyes guys
don't forget a blue shirt it always
works i'm a big believer that you need
to have your your signature scent but no
one needs to smell you half a block
coming you want to make sure they get up
close before they smell it of course one
of the biggest things to remember when
you're going out on a date don't be late
so if you can combine the idea that
you're going to be on time
and still have a sense of rugged glamour
nothing beats an oversized chronograph
watch you know it's not a lightweight
dress watch that you'd want to wear
that's something you want to keep for
you know monday morning meetings but
definitely think about that watch keeps
you on time gives you a powerful edge
you